- [Voiceover] Now that
we've read this passage,
let's see if we can answer the questions.
So the first question:
The stance Jordan takes in the passage
is best described as that of
an idealist setting forth principles.
Now that seems actually not too bad.
She talks about that
it's actually the role
of the congress to be the inquisitors,
the role to kind of impeach the President,
but sets up principles
when it's appropriate
and when it's not.
It shouldn't be for petty reasons.
It shouldn't be for party reasons.
It shouldn't be just
because the President,
the Congress thinks the
President did a bad job.
It should be for major offenses,
gross crimes and misdemeanors,
so that's actually seems pretty good.
Let's see these other ones.
An advocate seeking a
compromised position.
There was nothing about this speech
that seemed like a compromise.
She seemed like she was
stating some principles
and in a fairly strong way.
An observer striving for neutrality.
There is an aspect where she kind of says,
"Look, this shouldn't be
about partisan bickering
"or, or, or about pettiness,"
so there is an element of,
and she wants to be solemn
so she definitely wants to be neutral
in that she wants to take it seriously
but she also says, I mean
this is her first line,
"Today, I am an inquisitor."
These are the people who are investigating
and might be accusing someone.
And she also says, "And I
am not going to sit here
"and be an idle spectator."
That's what an observer is.
An observer would be an idle spectator.
She's not doing that, she's taking action.
She is an inquisitor so I think
because she's being so active,
I think, and frankly idealist,
I think this first A is a better choice.
C, you know, I had to
think about it for a second
but A feels better.
A scholar researching a
historical controversy.
No way, she's in, she's in it right now
and she's not a scholar.
She's an active participant in the events
and it's not a historical event.
It's happening as she's speaking.
Let's go to the next question.
The main rhetorical effect of
the series of three phases,
of three phrases in
lines five through six,
the diminution, the subversion,
the destruction is to.
So this is here, "And I
am not going to sit here
"and be an idle spectator
to the diminution,
"the subversion, the destruction
of the Constitution."
She's not messing around.
Convey with increasing
intensity the seriousness
of the threat Jordan
sees to the Constitution.
That looks pretty good.
She's saying, "I'm not going to sit here
"and be an idle spectator
to the diminution,
"the subversion, the destruction
of the Constitution."
So that seems like she's,
she wants to communicate the intensity,
the seriousness that she sees the threat
to the Constitution.
Clarify that Jordan
believes the Constitution
was first weakened then
sabotaged then broken.
No, she's just saying
she doesn't want to be
the spectator to that happening.
She's not saying that it necessarily
already, already happened.
Indicating, indicate that Jordan thinks
the Constitution is prone to failure
in three distinct ways.
No, no, not at all.
In fact, later on, she talks about,
I mean she says, "My faith,"
not later on, actually right before that,
"My faith in the Constitution is whole,
"it is complete, it is total."
So she doesn't think that
it is prone to failure.
Propose a three-part agenda for rescuing
the Constitution from the current crisis.
No, she doesn't start
breaking off in like,
"Step one, do this, step two, do this."
So I think it is the increasing intensity,
convey with increasing
intensity the seriousness
of the threat she sees
to the Constitution.
As used in line 34,
"channeled" most nearly means.
So line 34, we saw it right over here.
"The nature of impeachment, a
narrowly channeled exception
"to the separation of powers maxim."
So a narrowly channeled exception.
So impeachment it's this, it's this,
is this kind of a very limited exception,
narrowly channeled that allows
one branch of government
to essentially accuse or
potentially eventually remove
or start the process
to remove the President
and it's narrowly, it's constrained
and so over here, not worn.
It's not a, it's not something
that's actually done a lot
so it's not going to be worn
out or anything like that.
Sent, a narrowly sent exception, no.
A narrowly constrained exception
to the separation of the powers.
That sounds right.
Narrowly siphoned exception to the,
no that seems, that
seems, that seems strange.
She's talking about
look, there's a, there's,
it's a very, it's a narrowly
constrained exception.
It's a, to when one branch of government
can have a deep, direct impact on another
and potentially begin the proceedings
to remove or accuse another,
in this case, the President.
Let's read the next one.
In lines 45 to 49, prosecutions,
so this is 45 to 49 so it's right here.
"Prosecutions of
impeachment will seldom fail
"to agitate the passions
of the whole community,
"said Hamilton in the Federalist papers,"
number 65,
"We divide into parties
more or less friendly
"or inimical to the accused.
"I do not mean political
parties in that sense."
So this is just saying hey look,
when you have an impeachment proceeding,
people are going to get
passionate about it.
Some people are going to be
sympathetic to the accuser,
some people are going to be
sympathetic to the accused
but it should not be along party lines.
So let's see, in lines, what
is the most likely reason
Jordan draws the distinction
between two types of parties?
To counter the suggestion that impeachment
is or should be about partisan politics.
I think that's right.
You can have two groups of people,
some who are, who are
on one side or the other
but it should not be along party lines.
That's why she says, "I do not mean
"political parties in that sense."
To disagree with Hamilton's claim
that political proceedings
excite passions.
No, they clearly do.
To contend that Hamilton was too timid
in his support for the
concept of impeachment?
No.
To argue that impeachment cases
are decided more on the basis
of politics than on justice.
No, and she's actually
arguing they need to be.
They necessarily need
to be based on justice
and they need to transcend party politics.
Which choice provides the best evidence
for the answer to the previous question?
So remember the answer
to the previous question,
we're saying this is where
she's starting to say
that impeachment should not be,
that impeachment should not
be about partisan politics.
She's countering the
suggestion that impeachment
should be about partisan politics.
So which of these lines
give us further evidence?
So line 13 to 16, that's up here.
That's unlikely to be it because we were
already down in the passage
and now to get further evidence of that,
to go jump up, well let's see.
"It is wrong, I suggest it is a misreading
"of the Constitution for any member here
"to assert that for a member to vote
"for an article of impeachment
"means that the member must be convinced
"that the President should
be removed from office."
No, that's not saying that this
should transcend party lines.
Lines 20 to 22, lines 20 to 22.
"The division between the two branches
"of the legislature, the House and Senate,
"assigning to the one to right to accuse
"and to the other, the right to judge.
"The framers of this Constitution
"were very astute."
No, this just talks about that hey,
the framers of the Constitution,
they knew what they were doing
by separating, by allowing one branch
to accuse and one branch to judge.
They're not talking about,
she's not talking about
party politics here or the
need to transcend them.
Lines 50 to 53.
"The drawing of political lines
"goes to the motivation behind impeachment
"but impeachment must
proceed within the confines
"of the Constitutional term,
high crimes, and misdemeanors."
So this is, this is an interesting one.
She's kind of saying look, you know,
political lines can help
motivate some of the impeachment
but impeachment must
proceed within the confines
of high crimes and misdemeanors.
It needs to go beyond so, this one is,
this one is interesting.
Let's see choice D.
Choice D is lines 60 to 63.
"Common sense would be revolted
"if we engaged upon this
process for petty reasons."
We actually want to
start at Congress though.
"Congress has a lot to
do, appropriations,"
so it goes all the way to,
so the ones, the lines from
Congress to transportation,
she's just citing all the things
that Congress has to do.
If they used, if it was these two lines,
"Common sense would be revolted
"if we engaged upon this
process for petty reasons,"
that might elude a little bit to,
to the notion to transcend party politics
but the one, this one right over here,
this just lists kind of the other things
that Congress has to do that shouldn't
get caught up in petty things.
Line 50 to 53 directly
addresses the notion
of political lines and the fact that,
or the need for impeachment to proceed
within the confines of high
crimes and misdemeanors,
so to kind of go beyond,
that it should not be politically based.
So I would go with C.